hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
and today we are here with another
money-making guide this is going to be
moneymaking method number five and if
you don't know where we are we are in
cigm um the main requirements you're
going to need for this method 60
smithing is helpful as if you don't have
60 smithing you do have to pay like like
15K an hour to use the blast furnace
kind of annoying but it's not that bad
um on top of that I think you do need
50k an hour maybe I think it's 50 we'll
check as the guide goes on just stick
with me I think it's 50k an hour to
actually have to like pay the NPC it's
kind of a gold sync and you have to pay
the NPCs to constantly like work the
machine for you because before this you
used to have Clans that would work it
for you and you'd pretty much have to
pay them the same so JX is like [__] the
Clans like let's just make all this gold
just go out of the game cool cool idea
by them I guess so works out um but yeah
so you're going to need 60 smithing
and some weight reduction gear this is
the best I could scrap I don't have any
[__] graceful actually I do I have a
cape and Boots of graceful which means
I'm [__] dumb but it is what it is so
you're going to want some weight
reducing gear you're going to want at
least 30 smithing is the necessity for
this guide and a coal bag would be
really helpful because basically um you
know you're just going to [__] need
to run coal and iron ore because what
we're going to be [__] doing is steel
bars damn it and if you can run coal and
iron ore in one trip you can make like
27 a trip and you can just keep [__]
running that [__] top of that you're
probably going to want some stamina
potions but you know if you want to walk
it you can do you but I think stamina
potions are probably more GP efficient
per hour so check that out if you guys
don't have the co bag you'll probably be
making about 55% of what I make in this
episode so just you know you can still
do it it's still good money but just
know that go forward so basically what
you're going to want to do find your way
to kigam you can go there if you have
okay also I feel like it doesn't need to
be said but you do have to have the
giant dwarf Quest done it's pretty early
quest just get that [__] out of the way
easy Quest points um you can get here by
running north of Camelot and go about to
the where the east side rock crabs are
you know the [__] East Side Rock
cribs East Side Rock cribs Crips um
anyways yeah you can go to the east side
of rock crabs go over there or you can
travel through the Grand exchange I
don't give a [__] how you get here so
you're going to want to open these
[__] doors you're on the east side
also of Kum so it is cool and go down
the stairs you're going to want to go to
blast furnace world and see all these
people that's how you'll know when
you're there um go ahead and go to your
bank and as you can see I have a ton of
iron ore and a ton of coal so we're
going to do probably about a thousand of
these and see how long it takes me and
how much money I make so yeah obviously
so as you can see you're going to want
to deposit your coins over here in the
Coffer and from what it looks like they
just diminished as time goes on so the
longer you're here the more you'll have
to use and uh yeah all right so what
you're going to want to do just follow
what I'm saying right now so you're
going to want to be stamina potted
pretty much all the time whenever you do
inventories just take out one bucket of
water take out all the coal you can fill
your coal bag go back get your iron ore
then run over here up onto the stairwell
or the little ramp I guess then once
you're up here go ahead and put ore on a
conveyor belt and then just press one
empty your coal bag and just don't be a
[__] like me and then press one again
and then you're good to go so then go
ahead and throw your water on the bar
dispenser and grab the bars there you go
26 deal bars and we're back off and then
just repeat this as long as you please
I'm probably about to do 1,000 see how
many or how long it takes me and then
we'll go from there all right so here we
are ending off the video as far as
supplies go I would say I spent I mean
while my Coffer does say that I was in
there for 20 minutes I was kind of like
getting everything ready to go um also
on top of that I probably spent maybe
$10 to 15K in stamina potions how I I
have no clue how much they are I mean
probably yeah around 15K on stamina
potions so and totally you can subtract
25k minus whatever I'm about to get so
as you guys can see here we're going to
throw in 831 coal and 831 iron ore which
is what I used that cost me in total it
was actually lower so 240 is probably
around what you're looking at so 240 for
that and then if we go back 831 steel
bars is 4 430 so 430 minus 240 is 190k
per hour and then you subtract I guess
the 25k so you're looking then at about
170k is per hour personally I didn't do
as many bars as I believe some people
can do from what I've been seeing I
wasn't using I wasn't using uh ahk
scripts or anything like that so this
was purely by hand so this is what the
average person can get without doing
anything like too out there I would
imagine that if you do like ahk scripts
and stuff you could probably get closer
to around 1K steel bars per hour I also
had to wait a lot for the machines I
don't know if that's a thing that
happens in every world but I feel as if
it probably wouldn't be or else it'd be
a bigger thing that people would
complain about but in my estimated
opinion you could probably make more
around 1K bars per hour which would hop
this up to around 200k is per hour or
200k per 15 minutes so realistically I
made about 800 to 900k per hour um
depending on prices I'm sure you can
make more or less there was a guide
recently put out by Autumn elegy that
kind of went over the whole Blast
Furnace thing so that may have
contributed to prices someone in my
stream yesterday said that they were
making 1.4 mil don't know how they were
doing that but nonetheless I was making
800 900k it's a really really good
money-making method for really low
levels and it I mean realistically oh XP
lamp while I'm doing a video weird bro
like Illuminati
confirmed um but yeah anyways that'll be
it for me today I hope you guys enjoyed
it was kind of it was kind of something
I like most money-making methods that I
do I've done them before so I'm pretty
experienced on what they are however
this one little different so if you guys
enjoyed feel free to hit that like
button um if you guys are watching this
within the first few hours of it being
released I'm more than likely streaming
so head on over to that if you guys want
to see when I go live in the future
while I'm streaming feel free to hit the
follow um you can also do that for my
Twitter both links are down in the
description um if you guys like the
video though feel free to hit the like
button if you have anything I can
approve upon tell me about it down below
always helpful if you guys want to see
what's going on with the channel in the
future hit that sub button and
nonetheless hope you guys have a
wonderful day and peace I'm the real
[__] XP lamp [__] oh [__] I tried to
click him I want be everything
[Music]
is
d